absent Thomas's Hospital in London
health workers are taking every
precaution against kovat 19 a woman who
developed symptoms shortly after
arriving in the UK from China is being
treated in isolation she had taken an
uber to Lewisham Hospital and was then
transferred for specialist care
uber says the account of the driver has
been suspended as a precaution but if
infected people are now in the densely
populated capital bought risk to the
rest of the population particularly
those using public transport rush hour
packed into one small environment lots
of people very very difficult with
millions of people taking the tube every
day it's a numbers game the the risk
would increase but not hugely
significantly overnight the Department
of Health says to avoid the virus you
should wash your hands often with soap
and water for at least 20 seconds
failing that use a hand gel containing
at least 60% alcohol and avoid touching
your face with unwashed hands but with
only a tiny number of cases in the UK
the risk of the virus spreading on tubes
buses and trains is still very low
continue as normal says the mayor this
morning like millions of Londoners using
the tube using buses used in public
transport F Public Health them we were
concerned and they let T fl and me know
I'd let the public know what I wouldn't
do is bury this away at the same time we
shouldn't be panicked or or along run on
face mask has led to a shortage for
dentists the British Dental Association
said they could struggle to safely see
patients as soon as the middle of next
week in China the Health Ministry has
reported a sharp increase in cases
though that's largely because in who
bathe the outbreaks hotspot people with
bad coughs and ammonia are being
classified as having the disease before
it's confirmed by a lab test most are
still mild this disease is still
predominantly severe in those who were
over 40 with a higher severity profile
that increases actually with each decade
after that and predominantly to that
severity is amongst men rather than
women and we haven't seen a significant
shift there are still relatively few
cases outside China and 80% of them
picked up the virus while visiting the
country the World Health Organization
remains optimistic that the epidemic can
be contained Thomas More Sky News